hey everyone welcome to LED live the
show where we talk about Christianity in
the context of culture today's episode
we're going to talk about one of our
requested videos it's talking about
Netflix's Messiah and in their words
does it con you or convert you find out
on this episode of LED live all right
first thing we want to do is thank our
patrons thank you so much if you don't
know what patrons are you'll want to go
to patreon.com/scishow
you can find HD digital downloads for
documentaries when we get them produced
behind the scenes access all that good
stuff it's there at patreon we'll put
the link on the screen and in the
description below for you keep in mind
that part of that is the post show
discussion that we'll be having about
this well it's not gonna be about this
show
it'll be about something completely
different but still our post shows are
interesting at least we think that we
are we think they're interesting and we
want you to check them out so we make
them just for you let's see we have
t-shirts t-shirts like this one Mikey
you got one on yeah led live you can go
to teespring comm slash stores slash
light wear and check out our t-shirts
we're putting new designs on there all
the time you're sure to find your color
your style your size on teespring and
and I become a patreon donor a turn your
get an excuse get a special shirt like
this that's not available to anyone but
they're gonna show the badge back
alright says your producer that's right
street cred because you helped us
produce this content that's right so
exclusive you can only get it from us we
also want you to know we have a store
for digital downloads on Vimeo and of
course our own website little light
studios TV slash shop where you can get
all the documentaries that we produce
they're not
YouTube typically sometimes I don't know
when this is gonna air but we've done
Taco Tuesdays so maybe that'll be over
by the time this gets out but you can
certainly rent our documentaries you can
buy them Vimeo is a great outlet
especially if you're overseas you don't
want to pay the shipping you don't want
to be you don't want to wait great
option and it's all HD as high quality
as we can get it we also want to hear
back from you comment on youtube you
know you may not always agree with us
that's okay we don't always agree with
you you can put your comments below and
we'll certainly take a look at them and
interact with each other we also want to
point you to video mission video mission
is a stock website for biblical
cinematic stock or you can find for
example like scenes from the life of
Daniel which we're gonna be talking
about today you'll actually see some of
the images maybe video that we use from
video missions so you want to check that
out video mission comm where you can get
high quality cinematics and there's
there's some free stuff on there too
right yeah there is there so if you're
looking for footage of Jesus I mean
there is some amazing cinematic footage
that the lumo project has allowed us to
to put on that site and offer for free
to anyone that needs footage of Jesus so
check it out can check out video mission
we also want you to remember our brother
channels sister channel but it's a
little like studios and hispaniola
okay so you want to check that out alex
is working hard he's starting to really
grind through some videos and get some
weekly content up there just like we're
doing on this show so it may not be
quite in the same format we're working
towards that but check out little light
studios in espanol and we want to remind
you that on a lot of our shows actually
you can toggle through and people have
put subtitles on there so I was noticing
as I was kind of looking at what what
people have contributed there's quite a
few different languages that people have
gone through and subtitled them so a lot
of them have Spanish of course there's
the auto generator which I don't know
how well it does but you know check out
those make sure if you need this in a
different language that
is available on YouTube and if you want
to know how to do that we've actually
made a little guide maybe we can put
that link in the description below so
you can see how do I put subtitles on
these videos that you guys make I would
love to help you we can publish that
guide and you can walk yourself through
that so thank you for those who are
interested in doing that alright so
today we're gonna talk about the show
Netflix put out called Messiah really
provocative title really intriguing if
you've seen any of the trailers
I might even play that for these guys
here but I asked this question and the
question is will he con you or will he
convert you so it's a very mysterious
figure that appears and shows up on the
scene and there's all these things that
start happening with this guy that
people are having a hard time explaining
he appears to be from the Middle East he
has a long hair you know it kind of has
kind of that Jesus type of look kind of
but he also looks a little bit sinister
in your kind man is this guy up to
something can we trust him and that
seems to be I guess the whole MO of the
show they don't really give you any
answers which to me I find a little
disturbing so it's almost like he is or
he could be but he couldn't be yeah I
never actually directly answered they
they is we'll see when we go through
this it's almost like they're like well
it is whatever you want it to be or
whatever you think it is interesting and
I hate that kind of stuff because you
know to me media is a platform you have
the opportunity to teach people truth
and if you just leave them hanging or
you're not leading them to the truth
then you're doing them a disservice yeah
so anyway we're gonna go through this
one of the websites I stumbled across
was the faith and family media blog they
were commenting on this show and so
let's take a look at here it says and
his preaching it's a pile of new agey
peace and love we are all one family
stuff with no deep theological grounding
specificity well I think that is what is
coming well you know what's interesting
about that kind of a statement right
there is because do you guys remember
when the Bible project came out that was
like Mark and ro
Roma Downey's whole project that was the
one thing that they said about that
oh you mean you mean the Bible yeah not
the Bible project yeah not the Bible
project those are different yeah but the
the one day that we're coming through
was this is not a theological thing it's
sort of this like it's interesting that
you say yeah we're gonna get to some
stuff later on so I'm not gonna spoil it
but I think you guys will be intrigued
by it what you find out as we go through
this content so you know this continues
it says is he the Messiah or is he the
Antichrist right is he supernatural or
just a super good con man the show says
yes to all of these at one point or
another year offering kind of solid
evidence that he's a fraud and kind of
solid evidence that he's not Wow so it's
just total like mass confusion confusion
exactly Wow so and we know who the
author of confusion is I mean that's
kind of weird to think about that that
you could have the same you could have
people watching the same show and be
like no he was Christ I know there's
been like now he was Antichrist mm-hmm I
mean you know we are we that lacking
discernment that we can't get a clear
answer whether he's not correctable
right yeah so you'll you'll see how
their their thought process as we as we
go through some of this so here's on
Wikipedia just to pull some data about
who's involved in this okay series was
created by Michael Patroni who is also
credited as a negative produce executive
producer and lead showrunner for the
series and then we find additional
executive producers include Andrew Dane
James McTeague you got to know that name
Mark Burnett and Romo down a horse here
we go again or yeah so it's fascinating
that I think Roma Downey is involved in
this because you know they made a name
for themselves her and Mark Burnett by
making biblical quote unquote content
now if you haven't seen our YouTube on
the Bible right I mean now you guys got
a check there we go yeah
we'll continue with who she she's a part
of this then yeah so Roma Downey helped
produce AD the Bible continues she
helped produce this movie on the Bible
and they had you know they cast the GQ
Jesus and you know the whole bit and and
as you waited through some of this stuff
we made a video on this years ago and
it's she is totally into New Age
teaching I mean I'm actually gonna go
through some of this stuff like what she
believes and what she's into right now
yeah
mark Downey was do you've heard of
Survivor the TV show survivor yeah you
have not heard of Survivor
so he was the producer of survivor
okay that was probably like his big one
and then since then he's done like
really well with reality TV stuff so
crossing over with Jonathan Edward you
might think well what in the world does
that have to do with Roma Downey Roma
Downey mixes a lot of Christian beliefs
and New Age beliefs and she was on the
show crossing over with Jonathan Edwards
and he channeled her dead mother for her
hold on the show and you can see this as
his coming I'm like TV Guide or
something says a reading with actress
Roma Downey touched by an angel touches
on such topics as her childhood in
Northern Ireland her daughter Riley and
her relationship with her co-star Della
Reese such man Angela what'd she have to
do with that she was the angel but the
other lady I don't know if you're gonna
mention her as well Reese Della Reese
okay yes I wasn't gonna talk about her
but she's also definitely into it she I
think is a minister or something in some
kind of like I think she's passed away
now be ritualism type church and she was
like really close friends with her oh
yeah so what I find really interesting
is Jonathon I went being a psychic is he
and Romo made this CD book thing is
called practical preying diet John
Edward using the Rosary to enhance your
life
and it's if you were to zoom in on this
thing you could see that says includes a
meditation CD featuring actress how old
is this thing this is I mean I found
this years ago you can find this on
Amazon so she's the one on the audio CD
for meditation to help facilitate this
and so what does it have to do with
Messire right because just because
people say they're Christian doesn't
mean the content that they're creating
is biblical yeah so whatever is
influencing them is influencing you and
so that's why it's a I think it's
important to see like well what are they
into yeah you know they're into talking
to the dead and yeah and beliefs come
out in your already the Bible is pretty
clear Ecclesiastes what is it 9 6 I
think that talks about the dead they
know not nothing like like if you're
speaking to a loved one who's passed
away that's a demon yeah sorry yeah and
so you know it's literally like here's
somebody that are not sorry yes sorry
not sorry there there's there's intimate
involvement here in the most pinnacle
thing that's the story of Jesus and it's
like man all those little demons they
just need one little foot in the door
and like they can crumble that whole
thing down from the inside out
yeah so this this scares me that you
know somebody like this would be
involved in master deceiver out of truth
a little bit of air yeah yeah
so what else well this is from deadline
says here Messiah is a series that will
have an audience asking big questions
what if someone showed up in 2018 amid
strange occurrences and was thought to
be the Messiah hmm what would society do
how would the media cover him what would
millions are would millions simply quit
work could government collapse said
Downey and Burnett it's a series that
could change everything what scares me
is is like isn't isn't the whole Jewish
nation still looking for the Messiah the
first time right
yeah I mean they set this is it not in
the Middle East but I was saying he
looks Middle Eastern I mean and isn't
the whole evangelical world really kind
of like involved in Israel to me this is
the devil coming out and saying you know
he's gonna come out as as as the Cosmic
Christ or whatever right he's testing
the waters how people gonna react to
this and they're even asking the
question how are people gonna react to
this and he's just waiting for his time
he's bathing the situation and when the
situation is ripe he's gonna come on the
scene yeah watch there what an easy way
to like find out you know like
psychological warfare let me let me just
see how the public reacts like like
world of the wars or whatever right
where the world's the world's yeah do
people kill themselves over a radio
broadcast that was telling you this is
fake or whatever this is like every
commercial break they would come back
you know this is a fictional thing but
people didn't realize that and then so I
mean how are people gonna react if an
alien invasion were to happen you know
we we kind of saw a little glimpse of
that back then yep so Michael Patroni
he's a creator of the series and let's
take a little look at his work there you
go you guys probably see you know my
screen miracles this is basically a
spiritual version of the x-files
according to its creators look at the
imagery for the right I mean it it's
creepy right looks like yes that is an
to the Hopkins on the fro it is yeah
right it's hard to see here you'd have
to get real close it says you can only
defeat it when you believe it you know
all this ominous creepy stuff so this
kind of stuff that Michael Paterna is
known for producing he was also the
screenwriter for Narnia voyage should
her voyage of the Dawn Treader hmm in
controversial yeah so here's an
interview a bit hand Michael Patroni and
the lead actor are talking about the
show okay so I'm not sure that what do
you think is a misconception that people
might have about the show
a misconception like something that you
feel like people might think right off
the bat or something you want people to
know about this here's what his here's
the misconception that might happen that
the show is trying to tell people what
to think and that the show is going to
give people answers and the show doesn't
tell people what to think and it doesn't
give people answers the show is told in
like a Russian kind of style where the
character the central character that
Metis plays is a mystery and you only
ever get to understand that character
through a pastiche of their points of
view so ultimately you never get to see
what he is you have to make your own
mind up it's very fascinating approach I
think so they're very clear like we're
not telling you what to think yeah but
we're not giving you any answers either
right and you know it's very interesting
I think of the time that you know pilot
sitting there asking Jesus are you the
King of the Jews you know and it's like
look dude I already told you there is
enough evidence on the table for you to
know who I am and just look around you
yourself said I was an innocent man and
and and here we have like the opposite
situation going it's just like we're
gonna throw all this stuff at you we're
not going to tell you really the truth
of who this is we're gonna this like do
you think a show like this really is
open-ended I it's hard to say as a media
producer it's hard to say anybody non
biased
you are biased as a media I wondered why
creative yeah yeah sorry we are coming
at this sorry like it's hard to not say
hey you know uh you know I don't know
let's just look in the and the good for
this it's like we've seen so many times
the confusion aspect of it yeah I'm
biased so he mentioned something he said
it was a Rashomon style story and that's
where the same event is recounted by
several characters and their stories
different ways that are impossible to
reconcile it shows that two or more
people can view the same event quite
different
now isn't that different than how then
how God works yeah you have four
accounts of the gospel why four well I
couldn't even told it with one why not -
I could have but it adds to the
testimony you have multiple people
saying the same thing the Jewish mine
they need a two for witness right come
on give you four accounts of the same
thing that you can basically say this is
true and hear that hear this is coming
at you in a no it's been a life I give
you four accounts that actually gonna
throw so much questions in the mix that
you won't be able to tell the truth yeah
so so yeah putting that all that out
there it just kind of reminds me I've
been reading books on ethics lately and
it reminds me of that you know the
morality that's not really morality
what's it's the term that man that
turned for it it's like a moral relative
morality yeah and it's it's like well
whatever you think or whatever you want
to believe you know and it's kind of
smacks of that as a postmodern - yeah
which it really isn't modern it really
goes all the way back to the Garden of
Eden post-biblical are you sure you're
gonna talk about this are you gonna talk
about like the biblical of appearing or
whatever the biblical okay yeah like the
second coming
yeah no I'm not quite taking that and go
with it but you are too sweet I just
wonder like if if a man came on the
scene like this should any Christian
believe that he is the Messiah according
to the Bible no because according to the
Bible it says that to the ground yeah
they say is in the secret chambers just
right there around on this earth i'ma
call you false prophet by media wasn't
you guys
so yeah we're we're we're good so James
McTeague he directed six of the episodes
okay do you know what he's famous for
well he's a second unit director on the
matrix any directed V for Vendetta
very interesting two movies that are
highly Gnostic is the storytelling yeah
I mean V for Vendetta I remember when I
saw that and and just just the whole
thing it's like they take a real
situation the guy Fox right probably
some real historical event but it's
flipped in such a way that it's really
telling the story of Lucifer himself
like Satan is like that was a story of
Satan and and it's pretty nuts if he's
worked on these to project the matrix
we're gonna do a whole project on the
matrix yeah like when they make they're
making another one and that's why I
think we need to but Gnostic Gospels win
over the matrix if you haven't seen that
bizarre as it was our presentation
really that that broke down the matrix
but interesting yeah I thought it was
fascinating that he was involved in I
think it's about half the episodes he
was directing ok so here's on his
biography this is from IMDB and when I
blow up here to one of his personal
quotes says I don't think anyone wants
to go to the cinema and get preached at
you have to evolve the ideas some of
them political some of them personal
into a film then the film becomes like a
Trojan horse you push it into the
villages wandering and it comes out as
another thing hopefully it's something
people think about afterward have
discussions about even vehemently
disagree on I like the idea that you can
have the entertainment and the political
idea in there so just I just want to
mention real quick for those people that
think that media does not affect you I
mean come on this is this is from the
Trojan horse's mouth himself we can put
a message in a movie what you aren't
aware of what's going on and it's gonna
come in here and it's gonna have a
profound effect yep I mean can you get
any more proof in the pudding this
and that is what you are putting your
mind in front of and saying
teach me something well they're
definitely offering to teach you
something you may not what it realize
what it is at first glance I think you
study the Bible to basically get a
clearer and clearer picture of a who the
Messiah is who your savior is I mean
you're walking away with that
information building a little a line
upon line precept upon precept to
understand who God is to basically say
that something is going to confuse that
and you're gonna walk away with not the
right answers to me it's like this isn't
even worth watching for the sake of
watching everything like this movies
just trying to confuse people that's
their purpose yeah which is Babylonian
right yeah I mean Christians are looking
at their watch when the pastor is
getting close to an hour or whatever but
yet they're binge watching this type of
stuff so you balance out the message I
mean they're probably not doing
devotionals and and then there's just
been an hours watching this man and no
doubt there's a lot of people that have
watched aroma donees other projects so
they're sitting there going well she's a
Christian she's putting Christian stuff
out there so she's a part of this
project then there must be some sort of
Christian interest I mean if they even
know I mean that wasn't like in big bold
print on Wikipedia you had to go like
kind of digging for that when I found it
I was kind of like oh oh well that kind
of makes sense but only what I knew
about her from before so I'm gonna show
you an interview from one of the lead
actors on here Michelle alone again and
I want you to see what she says about
being in this show okay the show is so
fascinating yes and when you have a show
that has religion politics faith you
know people gonna have a lot of opinions
yeah I mean you're prepared for yes yeah
we want people to have opinions and I
think the opinions are going to be
coming from you know depending on what
your own belief system is whether it's
politically or whatever you whatever you
worship whether that's your job or you
know an entity we want this show to
provoke conversation so you know that's
the beauty of this show
well it's certainly provoking our
conversation I don't know about other
people but I want to give you a little
bit of a flavor of her life where is she
coming from as an artist and actor if
you will so here's a couple of places
that she's been interviewed this one is
from vogue says here born again was
raised as a hmm fairly religious
Catholic but on her teenage years she
started questioning her beliefs she said
I remember listening to the readings and
thinking why do I need a priest to
absolve my sins when I have a direct
line to God myself she said and I always
took issue with why women couldn't be
priests I thought we weren't practicing
what we were preaching about inclusivity
hmm not bad questions I hope she didn't
leave the faith completely because of
the things she saw going on that
particular church or whatever well see
Boston Herald okay what does it says so
Boston Herald says the show has faith
appeal what does it look like from the
perspective of the cast here's what she
said in terms of her own degree of faith
in approaching material like Messiah
Monaghan said I certainly appreciate the
community of religion this has been a
very multicultural Cask but it didn't
really matter what any of our own
personal beliefs were I just so
appreciated I was just so appreciative
to be in a cast with such a global reach
that audiences all over the world will
be able to relate to all the characters
so very ecumenical yeah mmm and it's
just like that commercial of the Pope
you know we worship love and you got
Buddha and crucifix and all these
religions coming together man that's
that's what people are into they they
like that I like that all inclusiveness
of it they like it
so this one is from I think it's from
Interview magazine she said this I wrote
about my own experience with my own
faith I grew up Catholic I'm not
religious now mmm-hmm
big shot ding ding ding dinging horn
bells but I would say that I'm a very
spiritual person and you're always in
search of answers I really wanted to
understand someone that could be so
devout
so convicted and come from a place of
complete and utter faith that they would
no matter what choose their faith over
their family you can be new-age and
spiritual where you can be Buddhist and
spiritual like that doesn't say anything
and if you're like listen I'm not into
religious at all in the terms of
religion I follow the biblical model or
Christ that's really what that means
I'm just open up to whatever demons are
spirits is spiritual that's right okay
and so when you're coming from that
perspective you are you are putting that
into the show as you make it and that's
how you're shaping the view of the show
is from your own background and what you
think so it's it's fascinating to me so
I got I got a few more clips here from
some of the cast members I want you guys
to take a look at imagine the Messiah
would show up today but you wouldn't be
able to prove that he is the Messiah and
you wouldn't be able to prove that he's
not
what's fascinating to me about that
statement is are we just kind of like
throwing out the Bible then because the
Bible is there to help us identify who
the Messiah is and he's saying well you
wouldn't be able to prove let's imagine
you can't prove so are we've been
imagining a world without the Word of
God you know as I kind of listening to
this I'm thinking of the wide range of
people that are getting this wide range
of things right now right you're getting
this everybody's going and watching
Marvel and it's like you've got this
Messiah guy with a Messiah Complex but
he's really a sociopath called vanos
after you you know what I mean it's like
super confusing of who and what that is
and then it's like you've got these
Bible projects like this that are like
just really even throwing it in there
one more little mix and then you've got
all these religions trying to like be
like not just you know if you whatever
you believe we're all kind of on our own
path to kind of get there I mean you you
think about it
this is the seeds that are being planted
in the populace oh okay
no go I just wanted to add to that I
mean like what you just said like mega
church is well-known churches like
Kenneth Copeland so if they're like the
the protest is over
and the in the Catholic priest goes up
there and I guess we're all Catholic now
yeah dude it's like where did I see
something the other day that was talking
about the Catholic Church and equated
Catholic with Christianity mmm and I was
like hmm I always kind of thought that
Catholic wasn't Christianity I was like
its own like you know well even like
when we had Leo on here he said so your
mom was Krishna rice she said Catholic
she would say Catholic yeah Christian
yeah yeah totally different yeah yeah
it's like Catholics don't put the title
Christian on what they are but
Christians will title Catholics
Christian and Christian they're just a
little different certain things
it's things heating up you can see the
world all right so next next clip here I
want to show you guys yeah maybe one or
two more did with a terrific
a global narrative and it's very
provocative and untimely are you the
Messiah I am here to bring about the
world to come and so your show
concentrates on the question who is this
man is your world good is it evil what
you see will be your choosing one can
understand with the dawn of social media
how someone could come into place of
notoriety rather quickly as things go
viral that kind of mania that happens
through social media being the first or
were having that immediate access a
small simple story can get blown up
exponentially because of social media
because of the immediacy of news what
are you doing I'm posting it people want
to know the show uses it as a very good
tool for the relay of information I
think it also uses it as a relay for
disinformation you see how media has
such a big effect on people's opinions
and that it's not necessarily the truth
that you're seeing the show reflects
what's happening in the world news today
so there's a lot of interesting concepts
that are brought out there because
they're full-on admitting like hey look
whatever the media is putting out there
isn't necessarily reflection of truth
yeah yeah I mean is that what she just
kind of said and then it's like it's
like but this is a reflection of what's
going on really in our world today and
it is true I will agree with that what
we see in the mainstream media today
whether it be the news or whatever like
this is not necessarily a reflection of
what actually is going on there but I
think it's interesting is they're
talking about social media can blow this
up or whatever I think that's how the
gospel is gonna spread to the world you
know we have the Bible tells us that
before Christ comes the gospel will
spread to the whole world that wasn't
really possible before the internet and
social media and all this stuff so it's
like we're at that brink man is it
there's this spread of disinformation
spread of truth and we got to make up
our minds you know I don't know I mean
the disciples did a lot in one
generation without social media
yeah they later world shortly yeah I
don't know that it's so much weather
what technology we have is the amount
that we're filled with the Holy Spirit
that's that's my own personal viewpoint
but anyway I want to get back to the
show and and and seeing how the people
that are making this whether it be the
actors the producers the directors or
whatever their viewpoints are shaping
this narrative so here is Metis Debbie
he plays the part of Al Masai who is the
lead character he's this Messiah figure
so listen this guy's says some
interesting stuff okay yeah when I got
the part I was like yeah yeah okay yeah
I'm Mary Debbie and I play Elemis II in
the new Netflix series Messiah when I
was three years old I played Jesus and
that was the first role I've ever played
because I was in a Catholic school and
every Thursday morning we went to the
church and we played little scenes from
the Bible and the first role I had was
Jesus I think there was something that
was calling me in my spiritual journey
and then I believe that acting is
spiritual so both merged and that came
into my life with him the challenge is
that in this show everybody think he's
something but we never get to understand
who he is so I had to make the choice of
knowing who he isn't first of all and
then who he is the first thing I needed
to do is to get rid of all the
stereotypes that one can hear or think
of when you hear the word Messiah so I
watched a lot of documentaries and then
fiction about film portraying messianic
figures I really had to get rid of a
certain idea of what I wanted to do and
let the spirit just channel it and just
like be flowing with it if that makes
sense of the mystical it's a bit
witchy
[Laughter]
go yeah witch spirits witchy oh if you
have not seen our whole one on
channeling spirits and what actors
actually do this please you can watch it
right after this video but you need to
see what I mean so many actors do this
bad this guy just do this yeah and they
are they are opening themselves up to
the demonic world and I am telling you
like this stuff that we are seen that
this makes the Ergo go up on the back of
my neck the stuff you are seeing is
stuff literally told to us through the
media in the demonic world no but I just
want you to see what his character does
ok here we go
[Music]
of course it's that the ads above so
below seems like a lot of occult
symbolism right here in the shot so
there you go he's walking on water in
the show and so people are that's why
they have a hard time making their mind
up like man I see it the Messiah because
who's the only one that walks on water I
know the Satan is gonna perform miracles
great miracles like if it were possible
could deceive the very elect and I find
it just very interesting I'm just throw
this out here for profit prophecies sake
the fact that he's there in America he's
at one of the most iconic American
things here and it's like they've you
know highlighted this in this location
which is very interesting to me so this
character is interesting because all
throughout the show it appears as if
he's performing miracles altering of the
show there's a scene where he walks on
water which I just showed you there's
also a scene where he disappears from
jail just vanishes right Wow but it also
comes out in the show that he and his
brother were raised by their uncle and
their uncle is a trained illusionist
mm-hmm so it further adds to this ideas
like okay well if he's illusionist then
maybe you can just escape from jail or
what-have-you so it's planting that seed
of doubt like no maybe he's not you know
ekiz Criss Angel walked on water - yeah
did he yeah supposedly a lot you can do
with cameras these days yeah after me I
don't know maybe he didn't they read it
so you can tell this show springs a bit
from the popular ideas propagated by the
Left Behind series
you know those types of things a lot of
people read these as fact but keep in
mind what section of the book store you
will find them in do you know what
section fiction fiction that's right and
find them in the fiction store here is
from is it because it is fiction
[Laughter]
your own no Left Behind wiki on fandom
so I'm gonna pull up a section here
about prophecies
it says here according to Daniel 9:27 it
says it speaks about the Semyon 70th
week where the prince shall come from
verse 26 will confirm a covenant with
many for one week but in the middle of
the week he shall cause sacrifices and
offerings to cease and there will be an
abomination that causes desolation also
mentioned also in the book the 70th week
turns out to be the tribulation period
of the Left Behind series and a covenant
confirmed was the 7-year agreement
between the global community in Israel
regarding the license use of Khayyam
Rosenzweig's
synthetic fertilizer formula of course
this is a fictional book in a fictional
premise but they're trying to base it on
some things in the Bible from the Book
of Daniel and those things are actually
true and real and if you want to know
who the Messiah really is you can find
it from studying that book and
specifically this section I don't say
this a lot of people get the idea that
this 70th week is somehow completely
removed from the rest of the 69 weeks
and you can scour the Bible
front-to-back and you're not gonna find
a prophecy that suddenly has a gap it's
thrown off into the future and to an
undetermined time though and then
continues again the Bible prophecy
doesn't work that way God gives a
prophecy there's a timeframe you follow
the timeframe that's what's very
disturbing and scary about there's a
majority of people that believe that
they believe well this Daniel Daniel
9:26 and 27 is actually about the
Antichrist and you're like well a
prophecy about when Christ would come to
earth and be crucified
and and baptized and everything is
looked at as a prophecy about the
Antichrist so let's talk about that and
let's clear up that false theology for
lack of a better term and if you go to
Daniel chapter 9 you look at the first
couple of verses okay we're gonna look
at this and you're gonna find Daniel
opens chapter 9 by praying and it's a
very beautiful prayer and we're just
gonna look at that right now it says in
the first year of Darius the son of the
hash whereas of the lineage of the Medes
who was made king over the realm of the
Chaldeans in the first year of his reign
I Daniel understood by the books of the
number of the years specified by the
word of the Lord
through Jeremiah the Prophet that he
would accomplish 70 years in the
desolations of Jerusalem and he goes on
to pray a very beautiful prayer
he's very eloquent in fact he throws
himself in with a lot of his people and
he says you know what we've we've
committed sin transgression iniquity and
he is repenting and pouring out his
heart before God even though you can
read all the Bible and you'll never see
it or or read a bad thing said about
Daniel never and here that this guy is
and he's you know he's saying how is
sinful and and how much iniquity him and
his people have had committed and he's
just stirring himself in with their lot
and here he is studying he's actually
studying another book you know what book
he's studying I say no he's studying the
Book of Jeremiah hmmm cuz he said that
said by the word of the Lord and
Jeremiah prophesied that after seventy
years their captivity would be over so
Daniel being a student of the Bible he
was reading he's like you know what
Jeremiah said this is gonna happen about
70 years 70 years our captivity would be
over and he's like okay let's check the
clock here yeah this is about time to be
up I mean he's excited because let's get
out of Babylon you know let's get out of
this place so he's calculating the time
and he's realizing that this time is
about up so the Jewish nation had been
in captivity for a long time 70 years
and it's interesting as to why they were
into captivity for the
long the Bible gives us all the pieces
of the puzzle all we have to do is put
all this together okay so we go back to
the Book of Jeremiah chapter 25 verse 11
it says this and this whole land shall
be a desolation and an astonishment and
these nations shall serve the king of
Babylon 70 years so here he's you know
this is one of the the clues he was
looking at we know we're gonna be in
Babylon seventy years if you look at 2nd
chronicles chapter 36 and verse 21 it
says this to fulfill the word of the
lord by the mouth of jeremiah okay so
it's referring back to Jeremiah chapter
25 until the land hadn't joined her
Sabbath enjoyed her Sabbath's as long as
she lay desolate she kept Sabbath to
fulfill 70 years so in other words
Jeremiah did not pull that number out of
a hat he wasn't just randomly saying
it's gonna be 70 years there was a very
specific reason that they were in
captivity in Babylon for 70 years
okay very specific reason and we find
that reason in Leviticus she's gonna go
there real quick this is but in the 70th
year there shall be a Sabbath of solemn
rest for the land a Sabbath to the Lord
and the verse goes on to describe you
know sowing and pruning don't reap what
naturally grows but leave it so here's
the bottom line
God said back a little bit because he's
like look you need to farm your land
there's an agricultural people but every
seven years let their land rest give it
a Sabbath don't farm on it okay they
didn't do that and they didn't do it for
490 years which means every seventh year
in that 490 year period would be 70
times weeks there were 70 yeah there
every seven years times seventy is 490
years so for every every 70th year I
mean every seventh year times seventy
times they didn't do that and that's
where you get that seven that block of
70 years that they're in captivity so
for every year they didn't let the land
rest
they spent a year in Babylon
so highlighting here in Leviticus it
says you lies desolate and you are in
your enemy's land so it was even telling
them then in the Leviticus if you don't
do this you're gonna wind up in
captivity you're gonna wind up in your
enemy's land that's the consequence
so Daniel spring and an angel is sent to
him right and angel tells him about
another time period with the number 70
okay
only this time it's told as weeks not
years this is that 70 week prophecy that
we were just talking about that left
behind talks about and we're gonna pick
it up in Daniel chapter 9 verse 24 is
that seventy weeks are determined for
your people and for your holy city to
finish the transgression make an end of
sins
make it reconciliation for iniquity and
to bring in everlasting righteousness to
seal up the vision and prophecy and to
anoint the most holy
it's a question for you guys who are
Daniels people Jews God's people what is
their holy city Jerusalem Jerusalem so
it makes sense then that this prophecy
is about his people the Jews and
concerning Jerusalem you know it's not
some other people and some other time
it's about them okay and I think it's
interesting all the things that are
listed you have transgression you have
sin and you have iniquity or all the
things mentioned in Daniels prayers and
God is telling him look I'm gonna take
care of all that because Daniel when he
was praying earlier he said you know
we've we've sinned we transgressed we
committed iniquity and God's responses
I'm gonna cover all that I'm gonna take
care of all the same all the
transgression all the iniquity for my
people all right and that had to be like
music to his ears what a beautiful
thought may God is saying don't worry
about it I've got it covered I know
you've sinned but I love my people
anyway alright so this word determined
this is an interesting word you look at
his word determined here and this word
only appears here at least in the
language that he's writing which Daniel
writes
aramaic it's only appears here in the
bible but in the rabbinic writings its
basic meaning is to cut off okay and the
implication is it's cut off from
something that's longer right so what is
it kind of cut off from it's cut off
from a longer time prophecy
you know what that prophecy is 2300 days
yeah 2300 day prophecy right that's what
it's cut off from an angel Gabriel was
talking to Daniel in Daniel chapter 8
that's probably a whole nother video or
a link to another ministry talking about
the 2300 days and how this prophecy was
cut off of that but that's why the angel
is there he was there to further explain
to Daniel what was going on with this
prophecy and into to help him figure out
you know some things in Daniel chapter 8
because he was kind of left hanging he's
like I don't get it you know I don't I
don't understand in fact he was sick
praying about it and while he was trying
to figure it out so let's go to verse 25
says know therefore and understand that
from the going forth of the command to
restore and build Jerusalem and tell
this figure this figure is called
Messiah the Prince yeah there shall be
seven weeks and sixty-two weeks the
street shall be built again and the wall
even in trouble sometimes so Gabriel
tells Daniel there's something you got
to understand here okay and these are
the time markers for the prophecy so
it's from the commander restore and
rebuild Jerusalem okay that's it that's
a time segment until somebody who's that
somebody saw as a prince right yeah not
everybody knows it's Jesus right yeah
you're cool he's excited okay so what
what's fascinating to me about this and
you know study this a few times is I've
never could understand where you have
the word Messiah which means what do you
know it means anointed Louisiana good
one I've never understood how you could
apply the anointed one and and somebody
that's the
the angel is telling Daniel its messiah
the prince like how this could ever
refer to an antichrist figure yeah in in
verse 24 when it says that you know he
will come to finish the transgression in
sins make a reconciliation for iniquity
and bringing it everlasting
righteousness and to anoint the most
holy that that right there is the
mission of Jesus
yeah like encompassed into what he was
doing that's why he was here on this
planet wasn't here just to like walk
around and like do whatever he was gonna
make an end of sin he was gonna bring in
an everlasting righteousness and and you
know to to reconciliation for iniquity
though that was a very mission of him
Christ well I'm probably jumping ahead
of myself too but this is another point
I don't want to forget it but you know
never also find in the Bible where Satan
doesn't make a covenant with anybody
yeah hmm you know only God is the one
that makes a covenant and God's the one
that keeps the Covenant all right so
when you think of the word Messiah what
do you think of that wasn't that was my
notes but when I think of the word
Messiah I think of Jesus right yeah he
was the Messiah he's the one that came
to save his people from their sins
so what's amazing here is angel Gabriel
he's telling Daniel when the Messiah
will show up and he's giving time
markers for when we should expect that
so if you look at this as literal
sixty-two weeks
the temple was not rebuilt from this
point and it was not anointed in
sixty-two literal weeks right so we have
to look at it from a prophetic time
perspective all right so what's a
prophetic time perspective well
prophetic time perspective says that a
day in Bible prophecy can also be a year
we know that from a couple of texts and
I shared those with you you can jot them
down if you're taking notes one of them
is numbers 14:34 it says this and the
number of days in which you searched the
land even 40 days each day for a year
shall you bear your iniquities even
forty years and you shall know the
breach of promise okay so it's one text
next text is in Ezekiel 4:6 and when
balanced accomplish them
again on the right side and you shall
bear the iniquity of the house of Judah
forty days I have appointed thee each
day for a year so prophet Ezekiel is
having to stay on one side of the other
a certain number of days or a year so
this is how we can say okay a day in
Bible prophecy can can have a can mean a
prophetic year for skeptics that's
that's understood by all denominations I
mean that's they all say the seventy
weeks was prophetic weeks they just
detached this 70th week okay here's a
fun fact you remember when Adam sinned
and it was basically like you will die
mm-hmm in the David you eat the fruit
right no human has ever lived over a
thousand years up to that so literally
in a biblical sense
we died in that day yeah coming from
what was that period that decided a day
with the Lord as a also to prove the
point they think that the 70th week is a
seven years of tribulation so for a week
to be seven years it's understood that a
week a day is a year so we're gonna take
a look at some Bible math here we get
our little calculator out here
you guys remember these old Canon
calculators so 62 weeks science times
seven days would be 483 literal days or
483 prophetic years okay so the question
is when were the street and wall built
of Jerusalem during trouble sometimes
right
there were multiple decrees I've even
read as many as five typically you'll
see three or four but the most complete
one is found in Ezra chapter 7 verses 11
through 28 we're not gonna read that now
but this is in the seventh year of
artaxerxes and so we're looking at the
year 457 BC so if you move forward in
time 483 years you arrived at 27 beasts
it wouldn't be BC it'd be 2780
that might notice BC I don't know why I
put that mm-hmm
28 780 now keep in mind there's no years
ago right yeah yeah I was just going to
say that BC does actually count upwards
yeah so no Year Zero
um okay so now what happens in 27 ad is
the question
Jesus died yeah crucifixion guys know
there's a rented he's anointed oh right
right cuz cuz yes that's the question
again so yeah so what happens in 2780
Jesus I was anointed right right and so
how it was he anointed see what about to
their baptism right so I have this
little clip here that I put in from a
video mission so according to the text
we should expect to see the Messiah to
be anointed and that is when Jesus
starts his public ministry with baptism
right so now we have like this this also
a starting marker here for 27 ad now we
know we're in that last week okay
from that point forward and and what
happens in that last week well three and
a half years into it right in the middle
of the week according to the prophecy it
said the Messiah would be cut off right
but it said it wouldn't be for himself
and that's the way Jesus says he didn't
do anything for himself right he did
everything he did for other people and
so what happens three and a half years
into his ministry he's crucified he's
crucified yes all right so the Jews had
an image of the Messiah so what happens
the rest of the three-and-a-half years
right because Jesus has died you know he
was put in the grave he rose from the
dead and then one you know you got three
and a half years left of that prophecy
what happens well after that point the
gospel was allowed to go to the Jewish
people for the remaining of that that
time period you know Jesus said you know
I'm sending out you as sheep to the the
house of Israel you know and for three
and a half years the disciples worked
among the Jewish
nation they worked too for the house of
Israel after that three and a half years
the gospel went to the entire world this
is where you see you know Paul coming on
the scene and the gospel is available
for everyone the Jews that Gentiles
everyone no one's excluded anymore and
so when that prophecy ends you find it
ending it coincides with the stoning of
Stephen which Paul was at in fact he
held the coats of the men that were
there stoning Stephen he watched this
event happen and he was the first
Christian martyr he was the first
Christian martyr and and if you read
what Stephen says you know he's looking
and it's like he sees Jesus you know as
he's being stoned and I can imagine he
probably doesn't feel anything you know
God's probably protecting him from all
that pain and suffering that he would be
going through and yeah so he's the first
martyr gospel goes to the Gentiles after
that and the prophecy is complete so the
Jews had an image of the Messiah what
was that that he'd be this ruler that
would overthrow the Romans and like a
king yeah right he's gonna be this this
liberator military type you know freed
them from all this oppression you know
one of the reasons they had that image
is because there was a chapter in the
Bible the rabbi's would forbid people to
read heard about that and you know what
chapter that was don't Isaiah it is in
Isaiah 33 no one is a a fan 3 in Isaiah
53 talks about the Messiah as a
suffering servant mmm he didn't fit
their paradigm shift right they didn't
want a messiah who was a suffering
servant they wanted a messiah who is a
strong liberator I just want to read one
text from Isaiah 53 says he was taken
from prison and from judgment and who
will declare his generation for he was
cut off from the land of the living for
the transgression of his people he was
stricken so you know if they were to
read this chapter and all of you know
all of Isaiah 53 they would have gotten
a clearer picture of what the Messiah
was gonna be be like when he came
see instead when he came on the scene
some people were confused they didn't
understand it just like this TV show you
know you put on all these things about
the Messiah and they're creating
confusion so when it really comes people
are like well well who is it who is the
Messiah when is when is Jesus this guy
the Antichrist I mean there's all these
questions and swirling around in
people's minds it like they can't keep
anything straight if we go back to the
Bible though when we study the Bible and
we look at what it has to say about the
Messiah about what it says to be the
second coming and all that it can give
us a very clear picture amazing that
they had a chance at time and time again
to bring that to the forefront of their
mind yeah when Herod was you know like
go in search the Scriptures and tell me
when this baby was you know being born
or what's the prophecies they had to go
in terms and they had to answer yeah so
they they no doubt told him this is what
our scriptures say but yet when Jesus
tips on the see me and I am so Jesus
came to be a liberator for sure yeah but
not the kind of liberators they were
teaching or expecting he came to
liberate us from the power of Satan and
from the power of sin and that's what
Jesus is is doing still doing today so
we just continue with the the last
couple of verses of this as we as we
start to wrap up it says after the
sixty-two weeks Messiah shall be cut off
but not for himself and the people of
the prince who is to come shall destroy
the city in the sanctuary and the end
shall be with a flood until the end of
the war desolations are determined see
Jesus was cut off for every single one
of us in the middle of that seventh week
he died on the cross and you could say
that right there he stretched out his
arms open wide and love for every person
on this planet and because of that we
don't have to practice the sacrifices
and offerings anymore right all that is
done because Jesus was the sacrifice the
veil was torn from top to bottom
yeah so he caused the sacrifices to
cease he did it once for many and it's
it's done yeah so we were we're able to
be free from the power of sin because of
Christ so last few things this is what
you were touching on
it's what I had in my in so I want you I
want you to bring back some of your
thoughts it says in Matthew 24 you know
when it comes to like a messiah figure
and Antichrist figure or Jesus coming
again a Bible gives us clear counsel
some of the things that we can we can
know and and be warned about and this is
this is Jesus so then if anyone says to
you look here is the Christ or their
don't believe clear clear advice he
continues false Christ's and false
prophets will rise and show great signs
and wonders to deceive that's the whole
purpose
if those signs and wonders are to
deceive if possible even a lie and then
Jesus say to those who are asking for a
sign no sign will be given to them so
yeah we shouldn't be looking for signs
as our answer because enough information
has been given and it's basically like a
slap in God's face like you know at
times you you have told you all these
things like if you if you study you know
if you see me you will find me yeah
jesus answered you don't need signs you
need to study yeah yeah and when I study
you'll see the signs and world events so
he continues or we're kind of jumping
around in Matthew 24 that's a t-shirt
coming on but yeah I have told you in
beforehand in other words you're warned
now right you're warned from the Word of
God you're warning has already come
we've been warned ahead of time says
therefore if they say to you look he's
in the desert do not go out or look he's
in the inner rooms do not believe it
the Bible says this for as lightning
comes from the east and flashes to the
west so also will the coming of the Son
of Man be so what is Jesus coming gonna
be like everybody will see sure loud
right you're gonna see it you're not
gonna miss it it's not gonna you're not
gonna see it on some social media per se
if you have to see it on the news yeah
it doesn't line up yeah every eye will
see them yeah no no I'm sure we'll
probably have social media we'll be like
oh my goodness like look at this little
cloud in the sky that's coming in right
but you're gonna run outside you're
gonna see it yeah when he runs the dead
in Christ are gonna bust out of the
graves we're gonna be changed and caught
up not gonna be time to be like is it
was it not right yeah you're either
slain or you're going that I imagine
there's gonna be singing trumpets loud
experience
can you imagine recording that event as
it's happening imagine it like on social
media what is going on isn't it crazy
news that they're recording you with
your phone and you're missing the
magnitude of what's gonna happen and
that they're recording on your phone is
not gonna last much longer
you know for you it's really you think
you're you're recording this momentous
event and you have this permanence in
this recording mm-hmm but it's gonna be
destroyed in just a few short moments
all right all right don't want to miss
it don't want to miss it so are you
gonna find Jesus you're gonna find him
in the Word of God that's me man and
where are you not gonna find him you're
not gonna find him in popular TV shows
like the Messiah you find the Messiah in
the Bible so study your Bible and not TV
shows and you'll be much better off this
has been led live you guys have any
closing comments as we wrap this up
is there any a good video or source I
can go to study out the 70 weeks of
Daniel I have a good book and maybe we
should put this in the description below
or on the screen a book that I've used
is called in time delusions it's written
by Steve Wahlberg and a great book and
clear up a lot of things from the Word
of God compare scripture as he's writing
and I would recommend that to you
and delusions if you're interested in
prophecy you guys should check out a
couple of channels Bible flock box does
a lot of prophecy stuff third prophecy
yeah I hope through prophecy does school
of the prophets will put all their
descriptions and links in the
description below but yeah check them
out if you guys are interested in
prophecy I mean this stuff is like
unfolding in front of our eyes and it's
pretty amazing to me that we get a
chance to witness this in our day and
age but I believe that God's given us
enough answers for you not to be
deceived but you got to get in the word
be a people of the word right right
well thank you everyone for watching
don't forget to Like comment subscribe
hit that notification bell and make sure
you set it to also you'll know later
every video comes out and we will see
you next time on LED live thanks for
watching
[Music]
you